-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We do this thing every week
where I send
out a hashtag and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, with the $1 trillion
infrastructure bill
being signed into law this week,
I sent out the hashtag
#IfIHadATrillionDollars.
And I asked you to guys to share
a weird or funny thing
that you would do with
$1 trillion.
Within minutes, it was
the number-1 trending topic.
Number 1.
-Whoa!
So, thank you for playing along.
I appreciate that.
Now I thought I'd share some of
my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one's from
@rollipoli21.
They say...
Yeah, he should do that.
Throw it -- Just throw it
over the fence.
This one is from FighyaLenz.
He says...
-Oh, nice.
Come on! That's nice.
-That's pretty awesome.
-Come on.
-"Not my first rodeo."
-That's nice.
-"Yeah, I bought one last week."
This one is from xROC7x.
He says...
It started out really nice.
-Really sweet and then,
"No, thanks."
-Get out of there, man.
This one is from @BenPack3521.
He says...
Yeah. I know what
you're talking about.
And then you sell it back
for 50 cents.
-$3.
-Yeah, exactly.
This one is from @skyxswift.
She says...
There you --
-Oh!
Yeah.
-We love Taylor.
This one's from @fredkopecki.
He says...
-Come on!
-"One, two, three!"
-Snooze.
-You can snooze?
-Yeah, you can snooze Bruce.
-I don't know if you can snooze
the E Street Band.
-For a trillion.
-Yeah, that's true.
For a trillion, yeah.
This one's from @lmittz6012.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Not bad.
-Salute!
-This one's from @Mdmaddness10.
They say...
That doesn't mean anything.
It's always on.
-Yeah, whatever. It's on.
-It doesn't mean anything.
Please.
This last one is from
@maxhustles.
He said...
-Yeah!
-That would be awesome.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.